we are now getting to the point of being
able to talk about
easing mass guidelines joe biden in fact
today
is set to make a statement about masking
as a follow-up to what we're expecting
to be an easing of outdoor mass
guidelines by the cdc
i already said yesterday this makes
absolutely perfect sense
based on the science tucker carlson on
fox news
cannot simply leave it at that tucker
has to go further and not only attack
masking but demand that people
bully mask wearers if they see them
wearing masks
if they want to let's jump right into
this segment from last night uh first
part of the segment
as we did give in this grotesque version
of halloween went on for more than a
year and it's still going on not even
tony fauci still pretends that mass are
medically
necessary instead mass are purely a sign
of political obedience like kim il-sung
pins and pyongyang
we wear them because we have to the only
people who wear masks voluntarily
outside are zealots
and neurotics how neurotic are they well
we know
a pew survey from last march found that
64
of white americans who classify
themselves as liberal or very liberal
have been diagnosed with an actual
mental health condition
and you see them everywhere when you
walk down the street in any major city
now the mental health thing is very
deceptive and ugly
he doesn't mention what portion of all
americans have been diagnosed and even
diagnosed as a complicated term because
lots of people
have undiagnosed mental illness because
they refuse to go or don't have access
to mental health care
and also simply being anxious counts as
mental illness in the poll that tucker
mentions
that's all deceptive and and very ugly
and sort of used as a cudgel
but tucker carlson is right about one
thing there's an aspect
in which masks are theater i've been
talking about it outdoors
on bike paths and sidewalks especially
after vaccination there is an element
to masks being a theater it's a signal
that you care
before anybody was vaccinated one out of
a thousand cases were transmitted
outdoors
and they were in obvious situations
people crowded together in large
groups outdoors no one is getting this
walking by someone on the sidewalk
even jogging by someone check out the
recent statements from dr
ashish jah from brown university i never
believed that that made sense but i did
it to show i care
so in a sense there is an aspect of
theater
but we're getting beyond that now and
it's a good thing but somehow tucker
is attacking people's mental health and
then it gets much worse
if you dare to go on foot from union
station to the capitol for example in
washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment how could you
they're saying from behind the gauze how
could you
that's the question we should be asking
of them in return
the rest of us should be snorting at
them first they're the aggressors
it's our job to brush them back and
restore the society we were born in
so the next time you see someone in a
mask on the sidewalk or on the bike path
do not hesitate
ask politely but firmly would you please
take off your mask
now this is really stupid i'm ready to
stop wearing my mask outdoors
based on the coming cdc and joe biden
statements
i expect governors to go with outdoor
masking is not needed but other people
wearing them why do i care if other
people are wearing masks
but if it's the middle of summer and i
see somebody wearing a winter hat
i think that's odd uh it doesn't seem
comfortable
but what difference does it make to me
if someone wants to wear
a wool winter hat in the middle of
summer go ahead and do it as long as you
don't make me do it i think the judgment
of people
not wearing masks outdoors as these
guidelines ease
is something that will have to be dealt
with but tell other people to take off
masks it doesn't really sound like
liberty and freedom even
that uh so-called conservatives advocate
for
that's not making sense and then it just
gets worse science shows there is no
reason for you to be wearing it
your mask is making me uncomfortable
we should do that and we should keep
doing it until wearing a mask
outside is roughly as socially accepted
as lighting a marble in an elevator
it's repulsive don't do it around other
people that's the message we should send
because it's true
i don't know if tucker believes that
quite frankly like i think he knows his
audience will love it
but then to actually go into how to deal
with kids wearing masks
he says call child services
as for forcing children to wear mass
outside that should be illegal
your response when you see children
wearing masks as they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart
call the police immediately contact
child protective services
keep calling until someone arrives what
you're looking at
is abuse it's child abuse and you are
morally obligated to attempt to prevent
it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was going to get
punched in the face by a teacher
how would you respond to that that's
precisely how you should respond when
they tell you that your kids have to
wear masks on the soccer field
that is unacceptable it is dangerous and
we should act like it because it is
but too few of us have responded like
that so that is just
completely off the rails tucker starts
with
the kernel of a good idea science
doesn't support the need for outdoor
masking
great crossover agreement i will join
tucker in a bipartisan way on that issue
then he drops in
64 percent of liberals are mentally ill
oh wait hold on where is this going then
he goes in to
tell other people to take off their
masks
because you don't like it well hold on
now that's authoritarian
and overbearing and then call child
protective services if you see a kid
wearing a mask
hello police uh get cps here
there's mask wearing on a playground
what we need instead
are just clear new guidelines from the
cdc
not to weaponize mask wearing against
people
by involving child services or police
that's not that far from like alex jones
type stuff
about putting kids in camps or whatever
it's like a soft alex jones with better
writing
lighting and makeup that's essentially
what tucker carlson has become
and the colonel was was not
crazy uh about outdoor masking and the
cdc is set to agree
with the colonel of that and then it
just goes completely off the rails
my question is do you think tucker
believes this stuff
or tucker's doing it because he knows
his audience will absolutely love it i
don't know let me know what you think
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
letting my audience try it free for an
entire
month i love curiosity stream perfect
for people
like me or anybody who watches the david
pakman show
curiosity stream is kind of like netflix
for documentaries it's a streaming
service with
thousands of documentaries from some of
the best filmmakers
many are exclusive to curiosity stream
including documentaries on politics
science history
everything the curiosity stream app is
great
i use it on my tv phone and ipad
i just watched as i told you very
recently
engineering the future very very
interesting about potential future
technologies
and they always have the newest and most
popular documentaries
they have amazing ones that i can't find
on other platforms and
curiosity stream is just 299 a month
or 19.99 for a whole year but you
can try it totally free for one month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman